That's right, it's true that the intelligence that made the memories of the children of 10031 is like that
The memories of the girls of 10031 who either threw them away or died
All of them were written in the previous one cruelly  I'm a merciless girl, so I'm
going to be clear about
it.
The wooden floor doesn't belong to anyone, it's only for Aizu and others, and it's not
something monsters like you can do as they please.
When I was outside of the regeneration state, I've been designated for a long time
Yeah, yeah,
desperately desperate ana
I'll let you go It
takes a little more time to become a perfect god
I'll have the stupid child disappear before it's too late
th